a vision is about what you're here to
create
a vision that really works is one that
excites you
people want outcomes they want to earn
more money or lose weight or be more
productive or
reduce stress but the outcome is not the
thing that needs to change it's the
system that precedes it
i plan my day obsessively my calendar is
always absolutely full
and often weeks in advance wanna be
happy
build a life not just a business
i believe a life
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
ways to accomplish
any goal you set enjoy
okay let's kick it off with way number
one you've got to have grit
with robin sharma the number one reason
we don't achieve success
and we resign ourselves to mediocrity
and we get swallowed into failure and
discouragement
and it becomes sometimes so deep that we
can't see
the possibilities that our lives could
be i mean your life doesn't have to be
your current life 30 days from now but
most people can't see that and the
number one reason is this word called
grit researchers say the number one
defining factor of whether we become
successful or average
is whether we have grit grit is the
ability
to stay true to your vision and not
dilute it
when you get laughed at grit is the
ability to try an innovation
experience failure and to say i'm going
to continue
and i'm actually going to learn and use
that experience to get me closer
on my path to the mountaintop
i mean what the ordinary person sees is
failure the master simply sees as part
of the process
of refining your craft so number one
you've got to have
grip you've got to literally when you
get knocked down
force yourself to get back up because
then you start to develop
a new brain yes you develop a new neural
pathway
yes you develop new muscle memory and
yes you develop confidence remember that
every time you get knocked down
it's an opportunity for you to
develop more confidence develop more
experience develop more
inner power okay every time you do
something that you didn't feel like
doing like getting back up after you've
failed
failed or staying true to yourself after
you've been laughed at or told it can't
be done
literally you become more powerful and
every single time
you don't feel like persisting and you
do
you take back your power to the thing
that you gave your resistance to
way number two start small with mel
robbins
how many of you have ever thought about
opening up a restaurant
or starting a small business or
having some kind of side hustle doesn't
have to be a restaurant
give me a thumbs up or a heart or
something if you have a dream of
launching something of your own
you're not alone by the way in fact for
the first time in
history when the pew research center
did this study about the american dream
and i realized we have a huge
international audience but
at least in the united states the
american dream used to be
i really dream of owning my own home do
you know what the american dream is now
for the majority of people it's
i want to own my own business and so
whether you're interested in launching a
restaurant
or you would love to have a business of
any size shape or form
in any vertical that you can think of
this is a question that you need to pay
attention to okay because i know this is
also
impacting you i don't i'm terrified to
start
i know i have the potential to be really
successful but i just can't get myself
to actually
do something about it you know sometimes
when
the dream is so big the fact that it's
so big
becomes paralyzing because you think
about where you are right now and you
think holy cow that thing that i really
want
i don't even like how do you even start
when the dream is so big
so here's what we're gonna do today
we're gonna shrink it down because
you know me i am all about simplicity
i'm all about making sure that the
advice works for you because if it
doesn't work for you
you're not going to do it and i'm all
about switching how you think about
things
so diego first of all
i don't want you to think about opening
a restaurant
i don't want you to think about
launching that business because that's
something that will happen
a year from now what i want you to think
about is i want you to shrink your
thinking
i want you to think about
researching a restaurant
i want you to think about preparing
to launch a restaurant i want you to
think about
learning about launching a restaurant
do you see how just saying i want to
learn about launching a restaurant
changes how you feel versus
i'm launching a restaurant which feels
so big
you're just in a phase where you're
learning
and researching this idea
which all of a sudden takes all the
pressure off doesn't it
awesome so that's number one let's
shrink it let's not talk about launching
it let's not talk about building it
let's talk about researching and
learning about it okay so that takes the
pressure off
then the next thing that i want you to
do is i want you to focus on
something that i talk about all the time
if you're researching
and learning about launching a
restaurant or a business
all i want you to do professor mel has
an assignment for you
i want you to find 10 to 15 minutes
that's it that's all it takes
10 to 15 minutes and i want you to do
one thing for 10 or 15 minutes a day
that helps you learn or research
about the idea of launching a restaurant
how many of you are starting to feel a
little bit
lighter how many of you are starting to
feel like holy cow thinking about it
that way
i actually could get started today huh
making this smaller
and making it something that i'm
learning about rather than doing and
launching and
that somehow thinking about it
differently
frees up the ability to get started
amazing i'm so happy that that is
working for you so
i want you to do one small thing a day
so what could you do you could read an
article
about somebody that launched a
first-time restaurant
you could look online for 10 to 15
minutes for a local restaurant
networking event
you could search uh youtube and you
could look for
videos that are restaurant tutorial
opening uh things you could
go to barnes noble or your local library
and find a book
you could apply for a job on the
weekends
and work in a restaurant if you've never
worked in a restaurant to see how it
feels because what are you doing
you're not launching or building a
restaurant yet you're learning about it
and you're researching it and your job
as a student of this subject is to do
something every day for 10 or 15 minutes
in order to learn or research it that's
it that's all i want you to do because
here's what i know
if i get you to start doing that and you
do this every day for 10 or 15 minutes
which you absolutely can
guess what's going to happen you're
going to feel momentum
you're going to feel like you're working
on it you're going to meet people that
are interested in it
you're going to learn things that are
going to lead to the next thing that you
need to learn
and you will have mastered the art of
getting
started and by doing something a little
bit every day you're also going to
master the art
of continuing to keep going and from
there it'll snowball i promise you
i promise you as you meet people the
next thing you'll do
would be to learn more from them as you
read and watch tutorials about people
that have started restaurants as you
watch
television programming about it you're
going to feel more inspired you're going
to start to see i think i can do this
that's going to lead to the next thing
trust me when i say it's all about the
little progress
you make every day way number three have
a compelling vision with tony robbins
a vision is about what you're here to
create a vision
that really works is one that excites
you if you
say well my you know my resolution my
goal my outcome for this month this week
this year is to
lose x number of pounds that's okay but
it's not very compelling
it has to be a compelling vision it's
got to have something has the power to
pull you
not something you have to push yourself
to do those are two different kinds of
motivation
push requires willpower and willpower
never lasts
what will last is pull having something
so exciting so attractive so
somebody who desires so much that you
have a hard time going to sleep at night
you get so up early in the morning to a
rocket and take it to the next level
that's what you're looking to create
that isn't easy to get but one of the
reasons we do seminars and events we say
you know why do that why isn't why not
just read a book or something is because
when you get an environment where you're
with people that are being put in a peak
state like when you're going to
a sporting event if you watch the
sporting event at home it might have a
certain level of excitement but
when you're in a stadium with 50 000
people suddenly it has a whole different
level of intensity
when we feel that and the bottom line of
our follow through comes down to our
emotional intensity
in a different state of mind you're
going to come up with a much better and
more exciting vision than if you're
sitting the couch going okay what are my
new resolutions for this year and you're
doing it the morning
after the year started and you're a
little inebriated
and the football games on the background
probably not going to have the power of
focus there probably not going to have
the power the energy to create something
that's going to pull you for this year
and you got to do that so it's got to be
a vision that's compelling
something that you know it's going to be
a gift to make sure that it happens way
number four
prime your brain with john assaraf let's
say you have a goal
that you want to achieve but you have a
lot of self-doubt or uncertainty
you haven't done it yet or you've tried
and you failed
um your sense of self is gonna
have some uh trepidation associated with
it it's like
can i do this can i do this do i deserve
this don't i deserve am i smart enough
am i good enough
and so what you have to do is you have
to take that
goal that's a conscious goal and you
have to
impress the image the vision of you
achieving that goal into your
subconscious mind
why because the parietal lobe is part of
your subconscious
sense of self and you've developed your
sense of self over the last
30 40 50 60 70 years depending on how
young you are
and so when you take that image of
achieving that goal
and for one or two minutes a day just
one or two minutes a day close your eyes
and i want you to imagine see yourself
achieving that goal overcoming whatever
hurdles have ever
been in your way or in your way right
now and see yourself achieving the goal
use your visualization muscle your
occipital lobe
okay is one of the biggest regions of
your brain that you use
all day long to see things so when you
use this just little technique of
visualization just see yourself and see
yourself achieving that goal
you start to override the existing
self-image and identity that's there one
to two minutes a day is all you need to
see yourself doing that
the people who took their goals out of
their head
wrote them down with one little piece
which i'll share with you in just a
moment
were 50 percent more likely to achieve
their goals than the people
that did not achieve their goals five
zero fifty percent more likely to
achieve their goals
than people who didn't uh write their
goals down
and so invest a little bit of time
writing your goals down but more
importantly
why not look at them every day just to
cognitively prime your brain on
what it is that you want right so when
you have your goals and you look at them
every day
you're actually not just reinforcing yes
this is what i want giving your brain an
instruction to focus on everything
in your physical world and even in your
imagination that can help you achieve it
but you're priming your brain to move
from conscious
to subconscious by the simple act of
reviewing it every day
hey this is john asref and do you love
good books i love to read because
there's so much
wisdom in books you get to take somebody
else's knowledge
skills research pay 15 20 bucks
and you learn so much now i'm reading
this
awesome book called built to serve find
your purpose and become the leader you
were born to be and one of my
new friends really smart guy really
great guy who serves a lot of people
evan carmichael
wrote it and i'm going to read a little
bit from
chapter number one and
i love this piece and maybe it's because
i just watched
uh the series on tv on michael jordan
the last dance which is really great by
the way also
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent at something
everybody has a michael jordan talent at
something you just haven't found it yet
or you have and you don't believe
in yourself enough to go all in
to go all in right and you're a genius i
believe you're a genius
and so does he you're amazing you were
not meant to live
a photocopy of someone else's life
you were not created to wake up and do
work that is below your capabilities
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so lots of pearls and gems
and motivational pieces pickup
built to serve evan carmichael
rising star way number five plan your
life with jordan peterson
you plan your day much or your time
generally does this lead to higher
productivity yes i plan my day
obsessively my calendar is always
absolutely full and often weeks in
advance and
i plan in the morning especially when
i'm on top of things
and i plan each hour and
i probably plan each minute and yes it
leads to way higher productivity
you know you you decide what your goals
are going to be
you place them in the calendar use the
calendar as your friend eh
because what you want to do with the
calendar is design a day that you want
to have
or a day that would be good for you and
a day that would be good for you is one
that you're
that you're uh you know when you end the
day
you feel that you've moved moved
yourself ahead towards your valued goals
and that you've kept chaos under control
and
that enables you to sleep soundly and
with a good conscience and to know that
the next day is going to be at least
not worse than that day planning is
unbelievably useful and again
you know i i don't want to sound like a
broken record with regards to the future
authoring program but it really is
useful you know
you need to figure out what it is that
you're aiming at and why and then you
need to figure out how you're going to
break that down
over the months and the weeks and the
days but i would approach your calendar
like it's your best friend you think
okay i'm going to design a week man
that i really want to have and that
means you can schedule in leisure and
all the things that you want to do which
which you absolutely should do
and it's also quite fun to
give yourself minimal time to do
something complicated because it's quite
challenging to see if you can do
far more than you thought in far less
time and so that's a fun game and the
other thing you can do is like if you're
avoiding something
you could schedule in five minutes of it
say well like if you're avoiding
looking at some bills because you're
afraid of them you know your first
step might be to schedule in five
minutes where you just look at the bill
you don't do anything else and you know
you might be able to entice yourself
into doing that
so but i would say learning to plan is
unbelievably useful to schedule your
time because that's your life you know
but schedule the life you want that
means you have to schedule your
responsibilities off
obviously because responsibilities are
those things that ruin your life if you
don't fulfill them
way number six change your habits with
james clear
often when we set about to change
something or to achieve something
the first step is almost always setting
a goal uh and this is coming from
someone like i was very goal-oriented
for a long time right like an asset yeah
i was like goals were the things i
wanted to do in sports the goals the
grades i wanted in class the goals for
how much money i want to make in my
business
and sometimes i would achieve those but
then sometimes i wouldn't
and so i had this question like well
clearly i'm setting goals for both so
like that can't be the thing
that determines it and you see this a
lot that the the winners and losers
in a particular domain often have the
same goals like
every olympian wants to win a gold medal
sure uh every job candidate wants to get
the job
so if the winners and the losers have
the same the same goal then the goal
cannot be the thing that distinguishes
the two and the thing that distinguishes
them is the process
the system behind the goal this is also
important because
achieving a goal often only changes your
life for the moment
it's like you know say you're
dude just take like a simple example say
you have a messy room you know and you
set you get motivated and you set the
goal to clean your room
well you can do that in an hour and then
you have a clean room but if you don't
change the sloppy habits that led to a
messy room in the first place
then you just end up with a dirty room
again yeah so it's like treating a
symptom without treating the cause
and um habits are a better solution in
that case because if you fix the inputs
the outputs
fix themselves automatically right you
don't have to fight uh to have a clean
room if you have clean habits
and i think that's true in a larger
sense as well right people want outcomes
they want to
earn more money or lose weight or be
more productive or
reduce stress but the outcome is not the
thing that needs to change
it's the system that precedes it and way
number seven the last one before a very
special bonus clip
is set realistic goals with brian tracy
why people don't achieve goals it's
because of fear of failure they don't
feel that it's possible to achieve them
probably the reason for that is because
they set goals that are enormous
and big goals do not motivate you big
goals
destroy your motivation and take your
heart away
when i first heard about goal setting i
decided to double my income in 30 days
and at the end of 30 days i went into a
slump and then i realized that doubling
your income in 30 days is pretty
ridiculous
it's taken you your whole life to get to
where it is today
doubling your income in 30 days is
ridiculous so i set a goal to increase
my income by 50
in 12 months and then i sat down and i
made a list of all the different things
that i could do or stop doing
that would contribute toward me
increasing my value
and increasing my income and of course
since i was in sales and business i had
a lot of control over my
activity levels people say well i work
for a company i have a fixed salary
well it's not possible to double your
income in a situation like that it's
just
you have to be realistic so when we talk
about goals they have to be
definite they have to be realistic they
have to be achievable and they have to
be measurable
you have to be able to write down a very
clear number and then you have to write
down month by month
week by week even day by day or hour by
hour
the things that you need to engage in
the activities you need to engage in
in order to achieve the goal now i've
got a really special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through so in the comments
below
write down your single biggest takeaway
as well as your specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
the problem is not that you're not a
genius the problem is not that you don't
have great ideas
the problem is that you are not focused
you haven't said that this is the thing
this is what i have to accomplish today
this is the mission that i am on and
nothing is going to stop me
if you don't learn to focus on what's
important to you you'll never do
important things and live your life
reacting to what's important to other
people instead
so i recently started a new business
with one of my thought leadership
academy students jeremy he came to my
event last year
i was thinking about him on my tour this
year and said i want to start a business
with jeremy around youtube consulting
i get asked a lot hey evan can you check
out my channel hey evan can i work with
you haven't can i hire you
for xyz looking at my channel giving me
ideas
mentoring guiding me and it's just not
the business that i want to be in but it
is a business
and so i thought jeremy jeremy's going
to come on board he's going to do it
now when i recruited him and called him
he was not a youtube expert
and i gave him the homework and said
listen if you want to do this business
together it's got to be important to you
i'm halfway through my trip on my tour
i'm coming back in a month and a half
here's what i need you to know by the
end of the month and a half and i gave
him resources i gave him videos i gave
him
insights and analytics and said you need
to know all of this
know all of this and then when i come
back if you're ready we'll start the
business
and he did he focused he made it his
priority he knew nothing about this
and all of a sudden he became an expert
by every day
all day long grinding to learn
by researching everybody who is an
expert at this understanding their
methodologies their best practices
looking through all my videos my
thumbnails my strategies all the things
that i've talked about in the past
digesting it kind of like the matrix
when neo's in the matrix and
he now we can learn kung fu and now he
learns how to fly a helicopter
all of that stuff that's basically what
he did and when it came back in a month
and a half
i put him to the test and said hey let's
do two free calls we'll take two people
from my community and say hey
free free call let's go and he blew me
away with how much he knew
because he focused on it he was a guy
who went from knowing almost zero
to now being an expert to be able to
really help
give value to people and now when we're
looking at new people coming in
i barely have to do anything because he
already knows what i'm gonna say
he already knows he's already done the
work he's done the research because he
spent that time on focused effort and
this is where i think
a lot of people feel like they're never
going to win because you may not have
had the expertise you don't have the
education
it doesn't take long to become an expert
it's just
focused work that you're passionate
about focused work you could quickly
become in a matter of months an expert
at something
if you just focus in on it and dedicate
your life to that thing
that you love you can easily pass people
who are experts at something who don't
love their thing
but because you're willing to take it on
you're willing to absorb think about
when you went to school
how much of the information you had in
your head but
you had to read over the page four times
so if you're at the same page four five
six times because you got lost you got
distracted
that's not focused work because you
don't love that thing
but when you love something how much
faster do you retain it
how much more enjoyable is the learning
process how much better are you
really quickly because you love doing
that thing
and so jeremy got really good really
quickly because he loved it because he
attacked it because he focused on
because he made it a priority
because he didn't say well i'll spend
half an hour a week trying this new
thing
no that's not how you win now where do
we go from here we'll see does jeremy
want to be
a one-man band forever does he just want
to be a high-paid consultant does he
want to then bring on a team does he
want to expand do you want to have
products we'll see we'll see how that
business evolves and flows but he got
here in a really short amount of time
because of that focused effort and
energy and that's what i want for you
i want you to take that big idea that
you have we want you to take the thing
that you have great ideas you're a
genius you're a genius
why are you not winning why are dummies
winning from the same ideas as you from
like a half big version
of your idea they're off winning because
they focused on it that's the only
difference the thing missing
in your business's success story is a
lack of focus and a lack of momentum
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days click the link below
or if you want to empower yourself to do
anything you want click the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there